hey everybody is Jessie and today we're
going to learn about parameterised
routing I'm actually going to set it up
I started working on it before this this
live stream because I thought it would
take a long time and it turns out I
pretty much got most of it done
beforehand which is a good problem to
have but I'm going to go through it and
kind of test it with all of you and I'm
a little bit nervous because it worked
so fast with very few problems so I'm
expecting something to break I don't
know if you all have that that same
feeling sometimes when things just work
a little bit nervous but god it's going
to break I said know it so I have a lot
of things to share with you it's been
it's been a while since my last
livestream was Tuesday yeah so it's been
a while so the white I went to syntax
con in Charleston South Carolina last
week and so that's why I wasn't
streaming the Wi-Fi at the conference
was not reliable enough to stream from
it kept making me sign back in and so
that I don't think there was any way I
couldn't I couldn't even do a speed test
to see the speeds has just failed the
Wi-Fi at the hotel was better but by the
time I got done with the conference got
something to eat and got back to my
hotel I was honestly just I was kind of
tired and I didn't think it would be a
great stream so I missed streaming but
now I'm back and I'm refreshed I did
some
interviews with some people at syntax
con and I'm going to share those with
you we I think we're going to watch one
at the end of this video so the way I
did is I just filmed people ask him a
few questions and I filmed them on on my
phone and I'll just play the video what
I'm hoping will happen is I can play the
video and you guys watch it on my screen
and the audio will come through the
speakers and hopefully the mic will pick
it up I didn't try it yet I'm not sure
if it'll work if you know of any other
way that I could get working in like two
minutes
that would be better let me know I'm
using OBS for for my streaming so if
anybody's familiar with that but I think
it it should work we'll see how it goes
but I have I think maybe about five
videos so as i stream i'll just do like
one a day i also took a lot of notes and
you know some of my thoughts on the
different talks in the conference so
i'll be sharing those with you from time
to time and kind of giving you a just a
quick summary of some of the things that
were talked about there's some some
really cool stuff exciting things
Charleston is a great city if you ever
get a chance to visit there were to go
to centaurs Cohen I definitely recommend
it
great food especially great seafood
they're right you know right on the
ocean there so anyway enough enough
about my trip let's let's get to it I
want to show you I'll show you the code
so here's what we've done probably since
let me let me think what's the last
thing you will saw okay so I think the
last time I I didn't have we definitely
didn't have a server AS VAL we were
using the default routing that comes
with next Jas so if you're just joining
us and you haven't seen any of the other
videos we're building a site with react
we use next j/s as our boiler plate and
that comes built in with routing and
with server-side rendering so it allowed
us to get a react app up and running
really fast but what we want to be able
to do and this is where the
parameterised routing comes in is when
you go so normally when you go to a
website that has a blog you click to go
to a certain post to an individual blog
post we don't we don't know how many
blog posts are going to be there so I
I'm not going to manually hard code
pages and and necks you see let me let
me zoom in here so if you see this pages
section with next everything you want to
be a page has to be in this pages folder
so we definitely don't want to hard-code
all of this so what we need to do is
make a way for pages to just be kind of
built on the fly and that's the
parameterised routing so what we want to
happen is when someone goes to the URL
that has slash news at the end then
there's going to be another slash and
whatever's on the end of that that's
going to be a new essentially it's going
to be like a blog post but we're calling
it news instead of blog so does that
make sense I know there's a delay so you
probably won't be able to answer me for
another minute but hopefully it'll make
sense as we go through and you actually
see it demonstrated so we are pulling
data from the WordPress API to do this
so that adds another layer of complexity
and we'll get to that so let me show you
what I've done I'll go back to my my
package JSON file when this shows us all
the dependencies so in order to get this
this kind of custom routing going which
next next is pretty cool in that if you
need something more than what
you know right off the bat with next all
you have to do is add a server j/s file
and you can set up your your routing
however you want really easy so all i've
added here is expressed and this LRU
cache which we don't we don't really
need for routing but it's really cool
i'll show you what that does after
you're done with the routing so that's
it I just added basically to get the
routing done just one more NPM package
so now let's go to the server does ASO
if you're not familiar with node this
might look weird to you if you are
familiar with node it might still look
weird to you maybe if I'm not doing it
quite right but some some of the I am
using es6 so you'll see there's like
arrow functions I'm using Const and let
so when you see constant let just think
there if you're not familiar with with
es6 or es2015 as its called
and then when you see an arrow function
just think like regular for now at least
this think regular function like think
that i've put the word function here and
these are all you know normal functions
so these basically they behave in pretty
much the same way and for our purposes
here that's that's all we need to worry
about so i've required express i
required next we're not going to worry
about this cache for now
here i've just set up a variable to so
don't know whether or not we're in you
know development mode or whether we're
in production I've set up the directory
and I've told it what directory to go to
and let's see this is for the cache so
we don't we don't need to worry about
that it's also for the cache also for
the cache
all right so here's what where it starts
so we have Express as our server and so
now we can go server dot git and now
it's getting anything that's the slash
basically we're going to render now I
have this set up to render in cache so
it wouldn't if you weren't doing the
caching it wouldn't necessarily do this
so let me go down to our function here
where it says render in cache so
basically if we've rendered this before
and we have a cache it's going to send
it the cached version of the HTML
otherwise it's going to yeah oh yeah
sorry I'm going to look at this okay
otherwise it's going to say render to
HTML so that's going to render on the
server side all the HTML so it's going
to get our calls sorry guys I was pretty
much ignoring the live chat for a couple
minutes looks like it's not - I'm either
boring you guys or I'm being confusing
the live chat is pretty dead
but basically what it's going to do is
render on the server all the HTML and
then send all of that to the client so
it's going to make the API calls to get
the data we need from WordPress it's
going to put that all together then once
we do that once it's not going to do it
again the next time it's just going to
cache all that so think how much time
that's going to save it's going to be
really fast it doesn't have to make that
whole trip to WordPress and to get the
data it's just going to be able to spit
out that HTML it's not even gonna have
to go through the process of rendering
at all so that's really cool now one
thing you'll you'll notice I'll go back
up to the top when we're just doing in
dev mode the cache time is really low so
I select 100 milliseconds so we're not
actually going to get the benefit and
that's because I
I want to be able to see the changes
quickly I don't want to have to mess
with with caching but once this goes
onto the server and it's live then we
set a much more reasonable cache time in
this case we have one hour I will say
this I grabbed a lot of this code and
modified it from other places and I I'm
sorry I I didn't put in all the places
where I got it normally I do that I'm
not sure what I was thinking I actually
grabbed this code from a project that I
did in March so I can't remember where I
got this and marched so if this is your
code and you see this let me know and I
will I will attribute it to you so I
mean I have changed it so it might not
be as easy to recognize but some of this
is actually just from the next j/s
examples in there git repo so this is
actually a part of their documentation
let's see all right so enough about the
caching I think we know enough about
that to understand what's going on so
basically all you're doing here is I'm
telling this server is if if we get this
URL then we're going to render in cache
the page that corresponds to that URL so
in this case say if the page says news
then give us the URL says news then give
us the news page right what would
normally be rendered with next is
anything this pages holder so just kind
of passing that on and rendering it as
as next would do now here's the the
different part this section here let me
know if if the font is too small I mean
you know what I'm just going to make it
bigger
sometimes I shrink it up to when I'm not
streaming and I forget to make it bigger
again okay so here's the cool part
now when the URL as news plus some some
string at the end we're going to do
something different okay we're
to make this variable called query
params and this is just going to be an
an object and it's going to say ID rec
params
ID this is just going to give us
whatever this string is after the slash
okay so we want that and we're going to
pass that so we're going to do render
render cache but we're going to we're
going to tell it to render this single
news page I'll show you the the mark-up
for that in a second and then we're
going to pass it this query params okay
so let's check out what's going on in
the news page and so I did this all
ahead of time because I assumed that the
server setting up the routing and stuff
would take a really long time but it
didn't oh but here's what's different we
already saw in a previous video how to
make an API call using this get initial
props function but now there's something
different we didn't have this before
this query ID this is giving us what we
passed in on the server right so we
passed then whatever the end of that URL
was as IB and now we're getting it here
so we can use inside of here ID and
we've used it here so we've used ID as a
variable that's going to give us
whatever that that string was after the
final the slash at the end of the URL
and so this is just basic what we've
already done this is our base URL to our
wordpress site and these are we're
getting posts and then we have this
filter we're going to filter by it by
name which is basically like the the
slug if you're familiar with WordPress
every post has this slug it's a unique
identifier a unique string so we want
that and we're going to search for that
post we're basically we're going to make
a call to the WordPress API to give us
data for just that post with this with a
slug name that that is going to be the
same as that
name at the end of the URL that we
pulled in all this extra stuff is just
I'm just telling the API what I want so
I want these fields
I don't need everything about the post
because I'm not going to use it all I
just need these these things so now
we're just going to use fetch we're
using isomorphic fetch meaning it's a
version of fetch that can run on the
server and if you're not familiar with
fetch when I say fetch think like Ajax
with if you were to use jQuery for Ajax
calls so all I'm doing here is just
putting these two strings together
because I want to search I want to use
fetch to get the whole thing together
and then what we return what we get back
from that response is going to be some
JSON data and it's going to get the
variable data okay so down here we're
going to do a lot of stuff with that
that data some of this is just checking
to make sure we don't get errors to make
sure our data is really there and I can
show you maybe it'll help if I show you
what the data will look like so let me
go ahead I'll just grab these and I'll
show you an example of what this data
will be if you have questions as I'm
going along I'll try to check back in on
the the live chat if I don't see it
right away at the end I will check out
everything in the live chat and I will
answer them if you can't stick around
for the end then just put the question
in the comments for the video and then
I'll answer it later on I try to answer
every question in the comments sometimes
it might take me a week or so if I'm
busy but I do try to answer everything
if you ask in the comments okay so let's
go all right so on my other screen I was
just making this
this call okay so I'm gonna have to make
this a little bigger because I know this
is this is really small even for me so
I'm sure on your screens it's super
small okay so this is what's returned
this is the data we get back and that's
in that this this data variable here so
we've got this post in this case this
the slug the ID for this I believe the
ID in string form is HelloWorld
so we've gotten this a little world post
we have a title we have the content we
have category the category number not
necessarily the name of the category and
we have some addition so I have a lot of
extra things in addition to the just
basic WordPress API going on so if
you're using the API you might not see
all of these things I'm not sure if
anybody's interested in me going over
how I set up the WordPress API but if
you are let me know in the comments and
maybe I'll do a video on that so
basically we've got the image in this
case I just I threw in an image just so
we can see the data from it so if you're
not familiar with WordPress when you
upload an image normally if the image is
big enough it will automatically resize
that image into several sizes so we have
a thumbnail version of our image medium
medium large large we have 2017 featured
image so evidently the theme I'm running
right now is 2017 which it doesn't
really matter what theme you're running
if you're just pulling data from the API
but it actually gives us two more
versions and then we have the original
version here at the bottom if we just
pull source URL we get the original
version we have categories here so by
default you just get the ID of the
category but that's not very useful
so I want the actual name of the
category in this case we just have on
categorized because I didn't set up
categories yet so
we can also have tags I have no tag
setup yet but we would see a similar
thing if we wanted to to pull all the
tags we can see that all right so that's
the data which is useful if you're not
familiar with the API hopefully this
will make a little bit more sense about
what we're doing so let's just see when
we want to work with this data variable
we do we have to say this props right
because what we've done here when it
returns this data it's become a prop if
you're not familiar with props last week
at some point I did a video where we
talked about prop so you can check that
out so this props everything we do has
to have this at the beginning and then
we can get to the variable which is data
okay so this props data now we're
actually getting into that JSON data
that I just showed you okay so all this
is checking for is do we actually have
any data here if so then we want to grab
the title so we want and I'm using
template literal syntax this is es6
es2015 syntax when you do this it's just
like a string except within the string
if you put a dollar sign and a curly
bracket anything in there it's
JavaScript so you don't have to end your
string put a plus and then do your
javascript put another plus and then
start your string again you can just do
it all in line so it's really a lot more
clean looking takes up a lot less space
so we we've dropped down into here and
into JavaScript here and we're getting
that data but we just want the first
item of that data so the way that the
data comes in from WordPress is
everything's in an array right so we're
grabbing the first item in the array and
since we only grab one item right we
only grab one post we're only going to
have one item so I just want that first
item and I'm
the title and then the what we always
have to put rendered when we want the
title or the content that's just the way
they set up the the the data from the
API I'm not exactly sure why but I'm
sure they had a good reason for doing
that but we always have to add this
render alright and then this is just
going to be our page title so if you see
we're actually going to use this down
here we have title and then I am using
dangerously set enter HTML and it sounds
a lot scarier than it is it is scary if
you don't know where your data is coming
from but in this case we control all the
data we we are going to be the only ones
putting in the data and pulling it in
now why would I need to set this
normally I would set this if there are
going to be some HTML tags I'm bringing
in
but I'll never bring HTML tags in
through this title but what might be
brought in is a character that's not
going to display properly so maybe like
an Anne sign I made it so that note you
know WordPress default for titles is
that you can't put HTML in there but you
can put those special characters in
there that will not look right you end
up getting like the HTML encoding
version of that character so that's why
we do it like this when we do it like
this we will get it we'll get it to
display how it's supposed to display
with the correct characters and not the
HTML codes for those characters and so
we've simply put in inside you know
react component inside the the render
function if we put a curly brace now
we've dropped back into JavaScript and
then now we're just adding this this is
you know the react way of putting this
in here and we've just at this title tag
right because we've made this this this
title tag function and it's just going
to return whatever's here now if let's
say this page returns nothing
maybe we misspelled it or that post just
doesn't exist then we're just going to
put News in the title
well what would happen if we just tried
to do this is that we get an error if it
returned nothing so we always need to
check to see if the data exists before
you try to do anything with it otherwise
you'll get an error you'll get the the
pink screen that react throws and you
you don't want that certainly for your
users okay that's the basic principle
I'll go through and show you but at
least one more time how we've done this
down here in the body
let me check let me check the chat
really quick to see if you had any
questions okay good
everybody's at this point either lost or
you're understanding everything and you
don't have questions so okay so down
here in this page I want to be able to
display something if the user tries to
get a post that doesn't exist so I've
created this error component I'll show
you the error component I'm sure I have
it up here somewhere there we go
let's bring it over here okay so the
error component all it does is it gives
us this you know main which our content
goes in main except for navigation and
footers and it just has a little tag
that says no content exists at this
address please try another page just to
let people know and it a more visually
appealing way that they've essentially
got a 404 error they try to look for
content that doesn't exist but it'll
look a lot nicer and I'll show you what
it looks like in a second okay so this
is just checking if the data is length
equals zero meaning if there's no data
show the error otherwise so this this is
a ternary operator so this is basically
an if statement a shorthand
creative statement within react with
within the render function you normally
you can't put if statements directly in
here so if you want to do an if
statement you have to do it in this way
with the ternary operator okay so this
is our if if there's no data then do
this let throw the error otherwise and
that's what this colon is we're going to
do this so otherwise we want to show
this bit of HTML so we're going to you
know just a regular markup we're going
to put everything in main we're going to
wrap it all in that we're going to bring
in our sticky now just like we're going
on all our pages okay a sticky nav
component and then we're going to drop
down into a little bit of JavaScript and
this is the check so we always have to
check for data in this case I'm checking
to see if a image has been uploaded if
no image has been uploaded then better
featured image is going to equal null
and then we don't want to try to get
that image because we'll have an error
so first is we're going to check see is
it equal to null and we want to make
sure not only is it we want to see if
it's equal to null but we also want to
see if it has an image size of large
because we don't want to show this image
here is going to be like a big full
screen image so we don't want to show a
small image so somebody happened to
upload a really tiny image I don't want
to show pixelated image I want to just
kind of stop that image from showing up
because you don't know somebody might be
putting in content into your WordPress
you know admin panel and they don't
really understand your image sizes and
how that that works so we want to just
protect the user from from seeing a
really pixelated image so that's what
that checked
so assuming there is an image and that
image is large enough then I'm sorry the
first thing so if there is isn't an
image or if that image isn't large
enough then we're just going to show
this title and play it out I'm sorry I
had it backwards let me start over so
don't confuse you guys so if the
featured image is not equal to null so
we have an image and that image is large
then we will add our title component
we're going to pass the title the props
to the title component of what is the
title that we pulled from that that API
data then we're going to give it the URL
of the image and we've pulled that right
from our data as well it's just kind of
long so this is just the same thing
we've got data we're accessing the first
and in this case only item in that array
we're going to go better featured image
media details size is large and then in
this case I'm pulling the source URL
I wouldn't always want to do that
because somebody could upload an
insanely large image so we'll probably
change this but for now it works if we
don't have a large enough image or any
image at all then we're going to display
the same thing we're going to do the
title we're going to pass in same data
as we did before for the for the title
but then for the image path I just have
an image file in there we can set that
up differently I've set it up in
different sites to actually pull random
image from an array of images we could
set it up so there's no image at all how
are we going to set that up but for now
I'm just putting this image in just so
there's something there okay and the
rest of its really a lot more simple we
just have our basic you know container a
row column and then within that column
where we're going to dangerously said
enter HTML again so don't only do this
if you really have complete control over
what data is
coming in don't grab somebody's random
data for this but I'm setting this to
pull in that data and I need to do it
like this because that's going to have
HTML tags and things in there that we
need to be able to bring in and have it
render properly as HTML otherwise if we
just try to do this down here and not do
it this way we daintree set enter HTML
we would actually see those tags printed
on the screen so in this case we're just
grabbing the content in the rendered
content and that's it let me show you
what it looks like so let's go in if you
notice we have some UI changes this is
probably what this is going to end up
looking like I had a lot of good
suggestions from you as to what this
should look like I ended up not being
able to do any type of shadow because
this is an image that is very much
wanted this little flourish thing here
and this is just I think it's a pain so
I can't get the shadow behind all this
I'm sure there's probably some way to do
it but I'm not great with image editing
and I don't have a lot of time left so
I'm going to do something like this it
could definitely use a little bit more
padding but we'll see I'm not like a
hundred percent super happy with how it
looks but that's probably going to end
up with it what we have at least for now
so we have to launch on Thursday all
right so let me go to news the news page
and you can see over here this is
actually you know we started our server
and we did have to make one change don't
let me forget to show you we had to make
a change in how we start our server I'll
show you that in a second but it's
actually told us that this is the cache
miss so we didn't have this page cache
so it had to build the page all right so
here's our just demo data but now we
want to go in and let's let's take go to
hello world all right so I know I have a
post that says the low world ok and this
is our this is the con
from that post so it's pulled it in I
don't have a page hard-coded in the
pages folder that says hello world so
this has actually created this page that
wasn't there before and as long as
there's a page with this slug within
WordPress we're going to get it and I
can have thousands of pages within
WordPress thousands of posts and I can
pull all of those so just you know we
built one template file this is not like
a new concept at all but we put one
template file and now we can have
thousands of pages based on that one
template so yeah I know templates have
been around for a long time but it's
still cool when you to do that to set
that up because it saves so much time
and your site looks huge even though you
only really made one page so for some
reason uh it's giving me a cores error
when I try to pull this image from
localhost so I'm not really sure maybe
I'll have to set something different in
WordPress so it's not actually pulling
the image but normally the image would
be behind here now let's see if I did
something so let me just put an extra D
on the end of world whoops
why did it give me that we might have
found a bug ha ha I think we did find a
bug
yes we did for some reason I'm actually
kind of glad this happened because now
I'll get to really do some coding um for
some reason we keep getting to the low
world page let's see now now it's not
taking us there while we're waiting for
that let me check out someone actually
commented design flaw um let me know
what is the design flaw are we talking
about this not working right now or are
we talking about this this thing behind
the title I think I would probably agree
with you if you're talking about this
title or or even the the other thing I'm
gonna actually restart the server I've
been having a weird error where it just
hangs and won't load the page and I've
never had that happen before I do have
an error showing up and dev tools and
I'll just have to research that and
figure out what's going on okay now
let's try to reload Wow
hmm all right
whoa it's not working okay which is this
is why I do this live so you can see
when things get messed up and how we
work through it I may not be able to get
this completely fixed before we stop the
live stream which is crazy I did test it
right before the live stream and it was
working I can maybe try to do a hard
refresh hey well at least I got the
image to load now that's really weird
let me see if it'll load this now I do
have another post that I know goes to
that is a real post now it's it's still
showing the same thing um let's check
our server well let me show you real
quick what I did have to do we change
the the dev it used to be the command
used to be just next now since we're
using our custom server instead of the
next one we have to say node and then
server J s is our command so that's the
only kind of difference when I first
tried this I forgot to do this part and
I left it as an accident acting weird
and I couldn't figure it out then I
remembered that so really only one other
file you have to edit to do this working
or at least somewhat working so what I'm
guessing is happening is that somehow
something is getting cached somewhere
along the way because it keeps showing
you this same data when it shouldn't
show me that same data so I'll have to
figure that out because I shouldn't it
shouldn't be caching caching okay I'll
figure that out I was I think we've gone
through enough to see how this works how
it should work and I'll have to double
check I'll go back and look at my code
when I did this sometime in March and it
worked in March and
see if I missed any steps and I'll let
you know tomorrow what actually was the
problem assuming I figured out by
tomorrow which I think I will I'm going
to go to I'm going to check out the live
chat oh and I want to show you the video
from CentOS con so let me check real
quick in the live chat maybe with
somebody from Latvia Netherlands
somebody asked the text editor again
they got a response it is Adam the theme
is the SETI theme SETI someone said this
is awesome thank you someone asked about
shortcuts Adam does have shortcuts they
ask specifically if the shortcuts were
like sublime I have not used sublime so
I don't know if they're the same
shortcuts someone asked if it's like
visual studio code does um yeah it's I
do use Visual Studio code and Adam so
Visual Studio code can let you import
shortcuts so I actually have it set to
use all the same shortcuts as Adam
someone from Nairobi oh ok somebody says
they're watching and learning in
Charleston South Carolina and they
attended st. talks Khan as well awesome
so really that that's really cool
I love Charleston I love being down
there hopefully I can come back again
next year for for syntax Khan I think
it's in first week of June next year if
you're interested check it out
somebody said my video becomes fuzzy
sometimes that's probably the internet
wherever you're at because my stream so
far it's it says the analytics on this
says the stream has been in good health
the whole time so I'm assuming maybe
it's it's somewhere else is the
connection problem what can I get my
navbar collapse to work and react I
would check is
is your navbar um are you running that
with jQuery sometimes depending like
I'll notice things won't work when I
just use like the hot module reloading
if I then do a hard like a refresh and
the browser manually sometimes they do
work the other problem could be it's
possible it could be an issue with when
the page is loading so normally you have
that document ready function with jQuery
and it needs to be able to to grab the
element once it's already on the page so
I would say those two things to look out
for just see about a refresh and if it's
the refresh issue with the hot module
reloading it won't be an issue when you
go to production because you're no
longer using that reloading if it's some
issue with the document ready function
it's possible that you may be able to
put it inside the component did mount a
function that you can use and react you
just need to make a function available
to be used there so I guess I've done
that before there is a way to import
jQuery into your react component and use
it and then there's also I've actually
made I don't know how great this is but
I've made a function outside of the
document dot ready function so it's
basically in the global scope and inside
that function I've done whatever jQuery
thing I need to do then I've called that
function from within the component did
mount a function within my component so
at that point
everything's been loaded then the
function gets called so you don't need
that document already function and that
has worked for me sometimes so hopefully
that was that made sense to you ideally
if you can just rework that into like
some vanilla JavaScript you can just put
that javascript directly in the
opponent in the you probably won't even
depending on how it works you might have
to put it inside of a component amount
or something like that but that would be
the best thing if you can
okay and somebody's talking about so I
mentioned before the design flaws of the
homepage soft software design for flow
control okay I'm still not quite
understanding so Nizar if you could
maybe explain it to me maybe in the
comments or something I definitely want
to know if I have a flaw here what's
going on
I'm just not kind of not following what
you're saying there maybe I just don't
know enough about it to realize what
you're talking about and if someone says
hit the API endpoint for a non-existent
AC with data is returning great idea
let's do that right now let me bring
this back and we'll go filter named
hello world so let's take out this D
here and let's just search okay we are
we are getting no data returned when I
switch that out so the caching isn't on
the WordPress side of things so that at
least narrows it down so thank you
patrick for that advice I'll just give
it another shot here just to see now
yeah it's still doing that so at least I
know whatever thing is wrong which I'm
assuming is caching we'll see is
happening on on the react side of things
and not not on the WordPress side
okay someone has said you know if you
want to squiggle with a shadowing can
send it to you two SEC's
well actually um that's that's a really
good I'm I'm very grateful that you
would to offer to do that if you could
I'd love to try it out and see if it
looks good if it works if it makes it
real I can't guarantee that I'd actually
use it so I'd hate to have you do you
know work for nothing just because I
don't make the final design decisions I
actually have to go back and and get
consensus on these design decisions so I
can't guarantee that I'll use it but I'd
love to see how it looks if if you're
still watching and you don't mind you
can you can check identify my email I
don't know I have a lot of my contact
info either put a comment in a direct
message me on Twitter and I can let you
know where to send the file to alright
alright thank you
okay so I've gotten through what was on
the live chat so far if you're still
sticking around thanks for watching I'm
going to try to play this video that I
mentioned at the beginning if you didn't
if you didn't hear I've done some
interviews so very short interviews with
people at syntax con in the conference I
went to last week and I'm just going to
play them I asked them for questions
just for I asked them who they were what
their name was what they did of you know
for a job I asked them what was one
technology that they're really excited
about one new technology and then I also
asked them what advice they would have
for people who are just getting started
in programming so I just asked those
four questions to everybody I
interviewed at because I thought that
might be helpful for for you all
watching especially if you're just
starting out so let me go
okay here's the video and this is Jabari
Dawkins and let me bring this back to
the beginning
hopefully this will play maybe an error
occurred it figures
I had it playing earlier today let me
try to get it going on my other screen
I feel like I'm I'm rusty at this I
haven't done it in like almost a week so
sorry about that things just aren't
going smoothly as they normally do okay
I got it playing on my other screen so
let me let me pull this over if I can
okay
okay so here's what I'm going to try to
do I'm going to unplug my head
connoisseur Oh and see if I can get this
to play over the speakers let's make
sure my volumes up all right that sounds
like it will end up being pretty loud so
let me know if you can hear this there's
a little background noise in the video I
took this like right when we were kind
of hanging out before the conference
started having breakfast so let's give
it a shot
where is narrowboat snackage oh oh so
pretty cool adjusting technological
learning louder's what Microsoft is
doing with the.net for current or DC
charts with new technologies they have
as far as advice I'd say really a
network network and get to know the
people in context I know just exposing
your technologies but also just acting
as a big talker
so ya never know any like thank you okay
let me know could you hear that and was
the background always too much the other
video should be better with background
was ended up doing the last few videos
outside just so that I didn't have all
the people talking from the conference
so I'll wait I know there's a little bit
of a delay oh wait a few seconds here
and see which if you guys can hear that
okay the delay must be pretty crazy okay
all right now it's finally coming it
okay we said the background was with a
bit much it was doable thanks for
sharing I could hear him actually met
him there but it was a little background
yeah sorry about the background was I
didn't realize until I watched it later
on how bad the background noise was so I
I wish I would have like maybe watched
it immediately and tried to do it again
we're actually we're kind of running out
of time before the conference started
but yeah the other ones should be better
there's only maybe one other video where
some people started talking loudly in
the middle of it but all the rest of
them should be fine I think I only did
five but anyway that's all I have for
now I'm gonna get to work on trying to
figure out what I messed up so it keeps
returning the same page to me and I will
I'll let you know maybe either in the
comments to this recording when when the
video gets posted or tomorrow maybe when
we start the next stream I'll let you
know what what went wrong but I actually
like when things go wrong because that's
like that's just how things go sometimes
you got to deal with with failure and
temporary setbacks but thanks for
watching especially if you're still
sticking around thank you for sticking
around all this time I went well over my
normal half hour and I'll see you all
tomorrow and especially thank you too
Tyus Durant sorry if I messed up your
name at all
thank you for editing that file for me
and oh
I'll check Twitter and check your your
DM on Twitter and see how that looks
the I'll put the link to this site I do
have this on an actual server now too so
i'll sync everything up to the server
and i'll put the link in the description
so you guys can check that out there's
already a link to the github repo for
this so you can play around with it if
you want and make any suggestions that
you
I have certainly no no expert I'm open
to your help thanks for watching I'll be
back tomorrow have a great day